this Hollywood sequel speak one-on-one
right here the last key is only the
insinuation that this is going to be the
last movie it's the last movie unless
this movie makes money in which case the
last key is not going to be the last
movie if this movie makes money there
will be a fifth and sidious movie called
the final key or the final door or
something and so on and so forth until
they reboot it that's your language
lesson for the day
[Music]
insidious the last key to insignia is
the last key is the fourth insidious
movie but it's an insidious movie that
takes place in 2010 it stars lin shaye
zaliche trainer or paranormal
investigator from the insidious movies
and now there's a new demon she has to
take down because it's a demon that was
in the house she grew up in she's the
only one who can do it now we have a new
insidious movie so this movie is not
without merit there are things in this
movie I actually enjoyed the insidious
movies in general I enjoyed because they
were horror movies they used horror
movie tactics but they also concentrated
on the story of the family they merged
the two very well to become what I feel
is a solid horror movie trilogy and
insidious the last key does bring some
of that element to it but I feel like it
was made by someone who saw what the
insidious movies were but didn't quite
know how to apply it to a new one the
family and story elements are there but
it's almost like the horror movie
elements took a backseat to that you
can't do that in a horror movie it's a
horror movie you're gonna have the
family story element you got to have
both merge well this movie did drag on
for the first half of it where you're
wondering if anything you're seeing is
relevant but in the second half that
stuff does come full circle does wrap
into being relevant not gonna give it a
full pass because for half this movie I
felt like I was just kind of wasting my
time I felt like this movie simply
existed to tell us where her two crew
mates got their shirts and ties from
there a few of those winks and nods of
the camera like ha because we're
referencing what you've already seen I
didn't need to see it but it's what
makes movies like this fun but movies
like this start running into problems
when you start to feel like that's the
only reason this movie exists this movie
starts getting bogged down when I start
thinking about it I cannot think of the
thing in this movie that actually did
scare me anytime I jumped it was from
yes a jump scare there in here there are
just a few of them I think in this movie
really built the tension in a way I felt
a good horror movie show yeah there are
scenes where she's crawling through the
dark yeah they're scenes where those of
crookedy old as weird basement but I was
never looking in the corners going oh my
god something could be there you know
where the things going to be and you
know that because you saw the trailer
stupid trailers I do give props to a
couple of the techniques they used in
this movie a couple of techniques
involving flashlights I thought were
actually really well used there's a
segment where someone has the big
paranormal boom mic so all the audio you
hear is from the paranormal boom mic you
listen to all the ambient hiss in the
background listen for that white noise
it made it feel like you were there with
the paranormal investigators I thought
they used good tactics in this movie but
it never paid
it's like it was teed up perfectly and
no one took the shot nothing scary came
of it I just walked away going those are
some neat techniques they use I hope
someone uses those interesting
techniques in a horror movie and uses
them for horror purposes I'd be fun guys
in the end insidious the last key was
not as good as any of the movies in the
insidious trilogy has a couple of neat
techniques they use they do use the
family element that the insidious movies
also used to drive the story but they
didn't merge horror movie and story
about a family as well as the insidious
movies before it did this whole scenario
is very comparable to the God of War
Games you have the God of War trilogy
we're gonna omit the PSP games just
stick on the trilogy the trilogy is done
and then they come out with God of War
ascension you're like do I need it not
really and if you never play it you're
still fine you have your God of War
trilogy stories that's how this whole
insidious thing is played out you have
your insidious trilogy you have the last
key do you need the last key no the
trilogy is fine enough if you're an
insidious super fan you might find some
things in the last key more enjoyable
but if you're not in a city a superfan
you're not gonna look at the last key
and be like oh what have I been missing
in the end I'm going to press on with
2018 and I'm probably not gonna look
back at insidious the last key for
anything so I'll say I'm probably not
gonna remember insidious the last key
and t-minus one day yeah I've already
forgot but it is a horror movie that
came out in January that's not complete
[ __ ] that's something alright guys so
insidious the last key have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]